all right ted well there is an uproar
surrounding a controversial tiger show
that could possibly come to the north
end of the strip the proposed tiger
sanctuary and magic show would be on a
vacant parking lot near sahara and
paradise it's where we find victoria
saha who listened in on a virtual town
hall meeting earlier tonight
this parking lot behind me is where
three bengal tigers could be working and
living amongst the businesses here on
the north end of the strip for a
year-long magic show tonight we heard
from the magician himself and local
residents on their concerns
[Music]
las vegas is no stranger to big exotic
cats in the spotlight often bringing in
a lot of interest from tourists and
residents it's an evening of the world's
greatest magic montana-based magician
jay owenhouse was able to argue his case
to commissioner take sigerblom and
residents in a virtual town hall and why
he should bring his tigers to this
parking lot our tigers will be living in
a great habitat while they're in las
vegas in late november a winchester
board meeting denied this proposal
ultimately living it to county
commissioners opinions from residents
ranged from both sides i believe that we
need to
bring these animals back to the strip
where they can show their full healthy
beautiful lives to the people of las
vegas i can't think of anything more
ridiculous to think of these wild
beautiful animals being confined in a
cage the well-being of the tigers and
the public seemed to be a top concern
i'm speaking about a person that is
experienced with working with exotic
animals
that can take the cat buy the chain and
walk it into a safe area so that the
animal does not have to pay the ultimate
price owen house's plan includes having
a 11 foot barbed wire fence along with
24 hour supervision
i want to add that back in 2020 oh and
else had plans to for this location for
approved a plan for his magic show on a
location on the south end of the strip
but those land orders backed out at the
last minute this
topic will be discussed again in next
week's meeting with the county
commissioners reporting near sahara and
paradise victoria zaha live local now
victoria thank you